damn you previously awning did we really
need to see the slaughtering of slinky
arm santa again what the hell is going
on
and why is there an avenger in my dining
room where oh he'll never get anything
out of him
see cb1 has trouble opening up k was fun
at first but she may now be the most
annoying marvel character to date and
damn it i think jar jar may even be part
of this universe now
t slurpers just go with me here jack is
obsessed with swords kate is obsessed
with hawkeye and eleanor is so invested
in kate's being safely separated from
clint that i doubt anyone would take
their eyes off of clint long enough for
him to do anything other than get his
coat and get the [ __ ] out how did he get
out with the sword but what i can do is
ensure your daughter stays safe he
cannot she's awfully composed around her
own idol if i ever met huey lewis i'd be
a wreck comparing hawkeye to huey lewis
the man wrote back in time damn it
kate's always been confident
never had to worry about her on that
front wait they're having this
conversation while she is sitting right
[ __ ] there jack now speaks sings the
words to the christmas song by nat king
cole and is just offbeat enough to make
me want to rip off my own ears and shove
them down his generically european
sounding throat and a happy new year
you know what they
life is shown
you never know what you're going to get
did he just butcher the life is like a
box of chocolates quote from forrest
gump i don't care if this is a
deliberate character quirk thanos was
right dust this fool no
that comfy right that someone in this
family decided to stop centering the
center stocking hanging on the fireplace
yeah they did that and they should be
punished also hanging your stocking
directly over an actual fire and screw
you tv show if you expect me to believe
that this fire guard is going to do
shittily dit to stop this festively
flamey foo bar i guess
getting laughed at my family is better
than being alone in the holidays right
putting aside the fact that being
comfortable with your own company has
inherent value in itself the real sin
here is that some people have no option
but to be alone during the holidays i'm
certain this was a very unhelpful
reminder in what is a valid piece of
escapism risk yahtzee stratego
excitement in previous episodes we've
seen hawkeye get first aid supplies so
why is he risking the defrosting of all
this fruity goodness instead of buying
an actual cold compress
he knew where the mission was going why
isn't he getting stocked up ahead of
time anyway
[Music]
he is squatting in an apartment why is
he confidently answering the door lay
low you bozo hey
i'm all for casual responses to
non-life-threatening situations but
pizza dog just mouth the entire upper
layer of cheez-its that deserves at the
very least a more emphatic no also
please stop giving the dog human food
they'd have just named him purina dog
none of this would have been a problem
believing die hard is a christmas movie
believing die hard isn't a christmas
movie having an opinion anywhere on the
is die harder christmas movie spectrum
instead of just [ __ ] enjoying die
hard for the masterpiece that it is
after all he's lost i'd expect hawkeye
to be more inclined to drink this slushy
treat from a container made of his own
scrotum than choose to use this thanos
was right mug see the
tree covers the parts that won't come
off yeah from the exact angle that the
camera happens to be viewing it from
right now but not from the rest of the
damn apartment what happens when the
tree comes down kate what then you movie
poster mauling monster have you ever
heard of boomerang arrows what why would
i ever want to use a boomerang arrow
hawkeye would be the green arrow at tv
sins you gotta show me how you just did
that asking a superhero their secrets oh
never mind it's only hawkeye that's why
i'm here i can't go home till i fix it
hawkeye is referring to all the people
he killed is ronin so i have to ask how
will it ever be over there's always a
chance that some dead assassin's son or
sister will come after him and his
family for revenge or a fist-chined
alien or [ __ ] michael clark duncan
the point i'm getting at here is that i
don't see how clint can ever be
confident that his family will ever be
safe from hawkeye and ronan's past
you should get some rest
you got a big day tomorrow no she
doesn't what happened to but what i can
do is ensure that your daughter stays
safe you're going to include her in the
mission just because she brought over
pizza in a christmas tree why is she
even sleeping here shouldn't her mother
be expecting her back home if you want
your two main characters to play
together just let them [ __ ] do it and
stop setting up all these [ __ ]
obstacles that you then ignore 10
minutes later previously on infinity war
part 2. you know i like to think of them
more
as our arrows yes and hawkeye fans think
he deserves his place in the avengers we
all have our delusions kate
yeah but what kind of ice wall if the
roof is high enough a wall won't help
your defense you need to be certain the
wall is higher than the roof go with ice
dome or at the very least ice shield so
that you can be mobile with your
defenses amateur i don't mean interrupt
you
oh this is you guys are
dedicated uh hawkeye sent me here on
official avengers business i'm uh his
partner slash best friend kate the
outright hypocrisy of kate turning her
nose up at the larpers while
simultaneously having a total lack of
awareness of the fantasy world in which
she herself is choosing to live better
as elle's beth of deep dale bragging
about being from deep dale which is
basically like bragging that you're from
northampton i can probably help you out
wait what kate is openly asking for an
illegal favor in front of a group of
people she doesn't even know and the
officer is immediately on board is this
another person i'm supposed to be
excited to meet and don't know it
fine i'm sitting larping all over again
to feel better about this nonsensical
moment if you make it worth my while
this is a request from the damn avengers
and these guys are pulling a dormammu i
know new yorkers have a reputation but
surely the avengers have banked enough
goodwill in the last decade to cover
fetching a few arrows i know he doesn't
like his attention that's for sure
hawkeye plays the pronoun game for this
entire car chat for no other reason than
to keep us guessing about who the big
boss is which means it must be somebody
we know already or they just go ahead
and say their name right where's tom
holland i need some answers
looking for this
or maybe it's the box cutter under the
seat kazi has a box cutter hidden under
the seat and a knife in the sun shade
but not a single weapon actually on his
person hey can i have my gun back
yeah what do you think i was relieved
that hawkeye didn't give the gun back
right up until the point he threw it in
a random direction i don't care if he
unloaded it first he still left a gun
somewhere in the middle of a used car
lot where it can be found by literally
anybody why not take it with him he
doesn't even have to use it or does the
mere presence of a gun maybe make him
realize how futilely ridiculous his
archery superpower is
i asked you to simply retrieve my arrows
not stage a play there are times when i
remember that clint is an [ __ ] and
this moment is one of them he did send
kate to a larp group what did he think
was gonna happen we've gotta we gotta go
we're in this together right well you
know what are you gonna have to change
no you're not and no she does not you're
supposed to be keeping her safe yeah the
lights no movement title of my
sex tape so if you see anything out here
just give me a signal okay all right
character continues to have conversation
with person who they should have heard
leave but somehow did not cliche good
evening sir
can i help you with your bags this is
i'm sure hilarious to somebody but did
kate really need to help this man in
order to use the elevator all she really
needed to do was follow him into the
building once he opened the door does
she think the grocery bags are hiding
her bow and arrows i think she thinks
the grocery bags are hiding her bow and
arrows
this sign explaining elevator capacity
says children count as people
[Laughter]
nonsense i was talking to an avenger
where there are like strobe lights
attached to the wall it's robot what do
you mean strobe light i don't know
yeah what do you see so we're just gonna
move on from the flashy strobe lights
that only started their strobie flashing
after kate walked in yeah i'm sure it's
absolutely nothing definitely not a
silent alarm or anything like that okay
get out of there now what
why that light's an alarm it's a silent
alarm for people that can't hear well
duh
wait am i smarter than an avenger oh
sorry never mind it's just hawkeye
convenient accidental zipline pinging is
all of the convenient types of
accidental convenience
audible head whoosh outside of a looney
tunes cartoon is extremely audible and
outside of a looney tunes cartoon
hawkeye the show where characters just
randomly discard firearms to be found by
any member of the public responsibility
sold separately
[Music]
what tell me these aren't the most
pointless restraints you've ever seen
what good are they if you can pull them
off after a couple of seconds okay okay
maybe it's because maya has some
enhanced durability or strength that we
haven't been told about
apparently not
if this was the only place that kate was
strapped in then she is 100 swapping
notes with gwen stacy right now instead
of surviving this
does kate know what the trick here will
do before she shoots it no but they're
the holy arrows of convenience so yay
plot [ __ ] is happening
ten zins for not acknowledging the
flubber that is clearly lining maya's
damn boots go home cake
it's over with two episodes left we know
damn well that it isn't i don't care if
you split your four and a half hour
movie into six 45-minute episodes
sticking this at the end of the fourth
part still earns you a third act
conflict cliche and double screw you for
making me do any math
you will give me the scroll or you will
taste the wrath of my pike where does
the hawk look
he looks in the barn he looks in the
attic he looks in a cellar he looks
everywhere he would hide
i fart in your general direction your
mother was a hamster and your father
smelled of elderberries
what what did i say did i say something
wrong
you put the wrong emphasis on the wrong
syllable
i will not look for you
i will not pursue you
but if you don't i will look for you
i will find you
and i will kill you
it's a movie marathon night right
check this out
[Applause]
i have a few more trick arrow heads you
can't just put them on any shaft
no i am against innocent trees being cut
down in their prime and their their
corpses grotesquely dressed in like
tinsel and twinkly lights you can either
drive yourself home or i can have you
collected
who are you i
am the vengeance
window
yeah not going out the window
why you scared moth are you afraid